what was this I was reading the notes on
you that you now believe that we're
living in an alien simulation one of
those guys no I don't believe it I have
had thoughts where we could where listen
I saw an article that said are we living
in a simulation I never thought of
anything like that
and that really [ __ ] with my head and
every now and then I wonder if we are
actually a simulation for aliens or
whatever that are messing around with us
so you think you don't even have free
will that you were programmed by aliens
and we're all here at their amusement I
don't believe this its thoughts that
I've had but JD why not read the whole
article I mean if it's gonna trouble you
that we might be in a simulation for
alien amusement I skim through it and a
lot of it went over my head I heard
something very brave about you and I'm
not being sarcastic you successfully
caught a mouse in your apartment and you
disposed of it well yeah I mean it was
in a we got in a thing like a trap and
you picked up the trap no my wife did
actually I knew it I knew it
Robin staring at you you know I can't
believe you know you were telling me
that he did something because they
handed me a note and said hey here's a
JD update he did the manliest thing ever
and a lot of the guys were impressed he
caught a mouse and like disposed of it
and I was like wow and his wife did it
probably in all the cases why didn't you
do it why did your wife have to do it
that's just how it happened
[Music]
give me that all right here's another
interesting fact as long as I got JD
here her JD and his wife celebrated Star
Wars on May 4th with a special theme
night they watch Star Wars and then you
made and ate a Star Wars recipe felluci
and garden spread based on the food they
serve at the Star Wars theme park yes
wow that is really dorky according to a
Star Wars fan site felluci and salad was
eaten in docking bay 7 at the black
spire outpost around the Year 34 ABY
after the Battle of Yavin yay that is
nerd that is nerd central yeah that's
right in the pocket of nerd he also made
a Star Wars inspired cocktail both of
them described it as gross the drink was
made mostly of rum and milk and was a
greenish blue color it is a drink from
the planet Tata Eun Qaeda weed sorry
really ashamed I don't know tattoos okay
look what's going on in JD's apartment
during Quarren yeah I'm sorry I missed
that may the force be with us and by the
way don't worry about that alien
simulation you take it from your buddy
over here you're not annex emulation
okay all right well maybe he ought to be